if you love all the birds and trees all
the fishes in the Seas if you think
videos of pets is as good as it gets
this segment in this review we hope your
furry dreams come true it's time to
celebrate Briggs animal friends
it should be its own show damn it
welcome back to Greg's animal friends
the segment where each guest is mandated
mandated to share a compelling video of
an animal that won't put you to sleep
Kat you go first I'm so glad you picked
me first you guys how are you we're
probably way better look at this video
look at it oh this goat I know I told
you wearing like a little sweater and
Professor I wanted to ask you this
because you are you jealous because you
wanted to make people happy right so you
had to write a whole book
this goat just has to put on a sweater
and walk about
is there a is there a tragic uh after
Story to this
[Music]
and then nobody will care anymore yes
and and you know what the sweater won't
grow with him it'll only grow out of the
sweater he'll be cold and naked and die
a lonely death
he's already on the way with that trick
leg if you notice when sweater leg was
longer than the other
all right Dr sad tell me your animal
story I've got I love dogs yes I love
play one of the chapters in the book is
about living life as a playground so
here you go put dogs in play and you've
got a beautiful video
um where is this do you know I don't you
don't know but we but that's one one of
the reasons why we love dogs so much is
because they share our obsessive love of
play look at this I mean it's fantastic
typical you have tenure you didn't even
you're just mailing this in you know um
you're right though so
a dog
yes well the first one in like you know
since the accident
but uh they play they have to play with
other dogs don't they they do because if
they don't they're missing a really part
of their social animals just like we are
and so we need to interact yeah I mean I
try to play with my dog but the the
officer says that's not play
laughs
welcome back Tyrus
all right uh Jamie uh you have almost no
human friends I assume that animals play
a big part of your life yeah like I'd
say my dog's my best friend but he
doesn't feel that way yeah
[Laughter]
professor's video
I like the dog at the wall I've always
been like oh I wish there were more
germs at a water park yes
um
so this is my video I'm super excited
about this this uh happened in Alaska I
made that up I forgot to look at where
it happened and
um dude what we're seeing is a video
I think we'd all agree this is the worst
hunter in the world yeah do you know
what I'm saying like if you go hunting
and you're sitting up in a tree and all
of a sudden you are tapped on the
shoulder
from behind by the thing you are hunting
this bear crept up behind him and tapped
him up that's the only reason he went
out with his friends is to look for
Bears the bear tops one and if you look
the Bear's an idiot there's a ladder
right there
and and some people are like go kill
that bear he's attract can I say
something though in the Bears defense he
was he had just seen a deep fake of the
hunter banging his bear wife hahaha
yeah I haven't seen it all yes you have
Tyrus Tyrus you often have actual stuff
from your own men yeah Menagerie is that
what it is it's a zoo thank you it's a
zoo is like little glass fixtures The
Glass Menagerie a play about a delicate
Zoo yes yeah my Disney's not delicate
it's hardcore that little goat would
have got eaten
unfortunately
we have the video of my so I recently
have got a bunch of new morphs leopard
geckos uh from my good friends you check
them out and they're really cool because
they look like little dinosaur they
don't think they're small they they walk
around the place like they're giant
monsters they look everybody and they
walk real slow and see some of the crazy
colors of the first generation you get
all kinds of morphs and different colors
and they're really kid friendly and my
my kids adore them but we got all kinds
of cool colors coming in this season all
kinds of new stuff hatching and see how
cocky and arrogant they are like yeah he
really thinks he's the biggest guy in
the room he even walks like he just has
this thing like he dares somebody the
problem is they're only this big
so they got that Greg complex
baddest little dude on the thing
you know this is what I deal with being
uh but uh you can get them at Wild Card
geckos I got a whole bunch last year and
this year and they're really cool but
are they affectionate yeah they actually
are people don't realize that about
reptiles man they they socialize just
like we do and they if they attach to
you that's why you should never catch
wild ones to be captive break because
when they come out of their egg they see
a person they identify them so they they
like to steal your body heat like they
always climbing on you and stuff it's
kind of cool
um uh do you do you suggest a number of
them like should you buy four or just
have one no I always you always start
out with one of anything Greg okay how
much would one go for now those ones are
very the crazier the colors get the more
expensive those two you saw right there
they're about 500 bucks a piece oh my
goodness what if you stepped on it will
you be a horrible owner and out 500
bucks but that's not important
small things I would
always on it read a story about Paris
Hilton I don't know if it was true
remember she did she like lose one of
her Chihuahuas in a closet
and then it died or something yeah I
died I don't know if this is real so
don't sue me Paris Hilton okay at least
not again
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else